[Music]
welcome back finley acura in the valley
automall
prides themselves on exceptional
customer service take a look
[Music]
when it comes to accurate dealerships
finley acura and the valley automall
well they're kind of the champs travis
congratulations on
eight years in a row the dealership of
distinction awards tell everyone what
that means
absolutely so dealership and distinction
is acura's highest honor
it's based on primarily on customer
satisfaction after the sale
it is a top tier award but to me what's
even more impressive is
some of your yelp reviews your google
reviews and i actually brought some here
when i get your thoughts on a couple of
these here okay um first one it comes
from
colin five star rating colin actually
came here from la
and says my family and i have been
leasing from acura for a little over
seven years now
and i've always had a great experience
with the team carmine
five stars i just bought a 2022 mdx
from finley acura this is my first
review i had to share
because i had a great car buying
experience and then crystal
five-star review she's been an accurate
owner for 14 plus years
and doesn't see herself changing from
this dealership anytime soon
what do you say when you get reviews
like this thank you that's what it's all
about
customer satisfaction and that's what
we're here to uh
to provide great customer satisfaction
can you uh can you show me around
absolutely travis i'm a car guy so to be
standing next to an acura nsx this is a
beautiful piece of machinery
tell everyone more about this car so the
nsx is going to be accurate supercar
but with design to be able to be an
everyday driver
hold on so someone is going to buy this
and they're going to go to albertsons
and get their groceries in this car
with the top speed in a car like this
191 miles per hour
this one's actually perfect for vegas
casino white pearl
[Music]
you buy a new or used vehicle from
findlay acura
your first oil change is free travis
what are some of the other service
incentives that you guys offer
so for the life of the vehicle we'll
also offer free smog checks
we'll do them right here at our location
as well as free car washes
and while you're waiting for your
vehicle to be serviced you know we have
all of our amenities inside like
fountain drinks cappuccino
coffee machines cold water whatever you
may need
big screen tvs and couches to make
yourself comfortable if someone has to
have a long-term repair done here do you
guys offer loaner vehicles
we do we actually have a fleet of acuras
as well as
enterprise cars jc so i showed you the
nsx couldn't let you leave without
checking out acura's newest design
the mdx this is a gorgeous what mid-size
suv
absolutely now how does the online
buying process work it's very simple
pick out the vehicle we'll work out all
the details in terms of the financing
we'll bring the vehicle to you along
with all the paperwork for uh signing
it's easy travis we covered it all today
thank you so much for having us out here
we appreciate it thank you
you can call finley acura at
702-982-4100 for more information or
visit
findlayacura.com mercedes over to you